[Music]
hello I also have something you know
what here I'll give you I'll give I'll
give you a little a little refresher in
the middle what do you say how about
this oh okay we need a break we need an
Opie break thank you okay so how's the
oakster doing doing great how's uh
what's this what was spuds Buckley how's
spuds Buckley doing great
um here's why he is doing fantastic he's
doing wonderful his life is great
um because he's been clipping himself
him talking about Anthony because he
knows that's the only one of his videos
that gets traction gotta get a little
juice on the channel as they say right
right right right so um and he's also
keeps re-uploading videos as you pointed
out before the show he's been taking on
his phone that he took on his phone when
he was in Ona The Glory Days that way
they serious can't make him take him
down like they did with other stuff
um so
in case you were worried Mercy because I
know this is a big concern to you
I have no problem with you liking both
Opie and Anthony
never encourage anyone to attack Anthony
went behind the scenes okay and attacked
him and the rest of the staff and the
rest of the staff okay
I I would really like to move on from
that but being Opie from Opie and
Anthony you know it's hard it's very
very hard to do I'll admit that and then
there are times I do have to fight back
as far as all the [ __ ] that has been
said and done over the years
but I'm not one of those guys
encouraging my people to go after him
because about your people
what people my my people my people hey
so my people my people yeah Forever My
People my people my people my people
[Laughter]
you know
dumb business first of all why split a
huge audience in half you idiot well you
split a huge audience in half when you
didn't go to the bosses the day after
Anthony was fired and said Jim and I are
asking for an immediate release from our
contract yeah given the circumstances
it's [ __ ] that you fired one of us
and now you've changed the entire
Dynamic and the circumstances of my
original contract and I will either
contact my agent or my lawyer or
something but I want my contract
dissolved and then you just start a new
company I'm not even saying don't be mad
you could you could do all that and
still be pissed at Anthony right you
could still be like
bro you [ __ ] shouldn't have said that
you should have [ __ ] known better but
also [ __ ] you I'm not gonna [ __ ] what
I'm gonna stay here and not do the show
that I created with this guy what me and
Jim are gonna do a show yeah
and that's the other thing Jim kind of
always was skated on that because he was
like yeah bro I like I stayed but I was
always Anthony's friend and I'm like
no you could have been like I'm not
gonna [ __ ] do this show of Anthony's
not doing the show you didn't do that
Jim I'm just keep that in mind yeah it's
two out of three right there so remember
when he [ __ ] back Jay Leno so hard
with the whole Conan thing too
yeah
anyway sorry
he did that not me
I'm trying to get to a place where I
just talk about Opie and Anthony fondly
and laugh about it and think about all
the ridiculous things we we did but it's
it's hard man people love the drama the
drama cells you're cutting it you're
cutting up the drama and putting it out
there on a platter you made a career on
drama yeah
I'll put up cool Clips on my YouTube
channel about some
some Opie and Anthony thing that's you
know there's no I will say this Opie is
the owner said to me and he's done a lot
of [ __ ] to ruin his own life that being
said he's also had a [ __ ] ton of bad
luck yeah because when you think about
like all he had he was left with so few
friends
like he had like three or three friends
left by the end and two of them died
well but to be fair
not bad luck he
El friends as he was an [ __ ] oh I
know but it's just when you only have
two left and then two of them it's like
whoa in it and it just does okay and
then if I have to punch back against
Anthony or something and then I watch
The Views go whoa
I mean 3 000 views
so I mean if I was in it for just views
I would I guess I would do more of those
videos like you're doing now this is
this is what you're doing this is one of
them oopster
operino this feels like when James
Robert Clark is like uh so just an
announcement to my normal visitors okay
I'm gonna be going back to my normal I'm
not going to address these it does it
all the time okay I'll do one video
about like vitamin D and white blood
cells and then the next day it's like so
it seems like fat man and gay men are
[ __ ] Jesus Christ man you had [ __ ]
eight hours off the board
the same way drama here let me clip a
video about me calling Anthony an idiot
look it opens the same guy I don't care
I'm gonna move on I'm gonna do new
things
and then the next day it's like oh what
do you mean Anthony I
don't do videos about him anymore
do you remember when remember when his
show was just him taking a [ __ ]
portable recorder and putting it in the
middle of the table of a like really
noisy Diner remember that
it's like this yeah so I am I'm over
here and I'm eating a pie with the Vic
Henley and the thing is it's like it is
a good recorder right it's one of those
things like what's the thing that
[ __ ] dick always brings with them the
[ __ ] drugs
[Laughter]
love you dick
that's [ __ ] good
um
jams yeah like it's just an audio only
but he bangs out pretty good it's just
it's a handy thing to have yeah you know
for quick little things but like Opie
would buy one of those set it up in the
middle of a giant table at like a New
York City Diner and then it was just the
sound of chaos dude those things are
literally designed to pick up ambient
noise yeah like that's what they are
that's what they're for just go out and
pick up ambient noises yeah he would do
that and then you can use it in your
like and then it would just talk about
nothing and tell old stories nobody
cared about about fishing trip it was
almost like if somebody if if it was
almost like if you're an FBI agent right
and somebody was we were investigating
somebody and somebody bugged the wrong
table at a wedding and you just had to
listen to a bunch of relatives inane
Babble for like two hours
so you know I saw Helen last week
actually yeah the surgery was great that
was fantastic and uh you know you know
we were just we were fishing last week
and me and Hank and he was updating me
on the surgery
uh it's a it's like a catch-22 I guess
if you love uh both of us that's great
that's great that's where it should be
who cares I don't like the guy
what we did was great
what we did was uh one of the greatest
runs in radio history Opie's the only
guy
Opie's the only guy
that [ __ ]
has a hundred percent of his audience
all they want to ask him about is the
Glory Days that's it like Anthony again
is he killing it with compound not
really but he's doing a show but he made
a thing where he hangs out with the new
people and people know him for something
else right and he's got like you know
Anthony to his credit going almost any
comedy club in New York he could go in
on Long Island he could go like they do
some shows on the road and like people
around kinda no compound and know these
Comedians and stuff
um and his Marquee star Chrissy mayor uh
and you know but he does but he's like
at least people would if they see
Anthony at a bar they're gonna go hey
what happened with Gino and Pat Dixon or
hey what's going on with you know in hot
water like they have new questions where
if they see Opie they're gonna go hey
dude you know what when Jim Anthony like
did they really like not get along you
know what I mean it's like old questions
and it's even Jimmy I'm sure people are
like you know making references
to no I guess they're probably no
they're probably big fans of his special
they came out on epics
I think they referenced Jim and sambits
yeah
I love that bit maybe they're too busy
giving money for him to do cameos as
chip chipperson I like Jim my favorite
bit actually is I love when you guys
bring in
um I love when you bring in like young
comedians that are making more money
than you on patreon but you and Sam have
no respect for and you stare you saw
that right stare at your phone and show
them no respect the whole time
that was yeah
anyway
oopster guys
yeah John Lennon and Yoko does anyone
else remember the lineup from Rock Roll
Circus let me skip ahead this might be I
was I was watching the uh watching you
got me saying watching I uh I I uh was
checking out the David Spade Dana Carvey
uh podcast they they uh talked to a lot
of old SNL members and um
he's so Opie
here's the thing with Obi Opie had like
two years that he remembers like fondly
right and none of them are like none of
them are when he was making money none
of them are when his career started
going well he has probably two years
maybe like the last year on Long Island
and the first year in [ __ ] Boston
that were like his glory years and he's
mentally stuck in them
so like SNL was good at the time he
probably like that's why he loves like
the black crows and the Gin Blossoms I
was like no I'm telling you see you know
I'm right 91 and 92 and 93 were Opps
[ __ ] up was the obsters [ __ ]
gloriers those were his letterman jacket
years in the radio world and he wasn't
making a lot of money he was young but
it was like but you know what free
trilly has a chili cook-off every year
no matter what no matter what and you
get to go [ __ ] do lie and you get a
200 Talent fee that's not bad um a nose
and he's just now it's like oh I've been
watching this Dana Carvey thing with
Dennis Miller
what the [ __ ] where are dudo synerg
listening to Rusted Root and like
[ __ ] watching the new Dennis Miller
podcast with David Spade the [ __ ]
happened man you just got stuck there
huh
uh Physical Graffiti you go Physical
Graffiti with your Zeppelin I mean
that's this really does I'm not kidding
see I told you he's oh my God now I'm
just skipping they run out of products
so now they're just making up stuff
oh futter we can't be friends
footer
remember footer [ __ ] I wish I wish
Frozen was here today remember other
merch [ __ ] I remember footer we know
footer actually a footer used to be on
the old mlr thing that we had he has a
band you know
footer ah footer
cannot believe I haven't heard that name
in so many [ __ ] years anyway whatever
look that's that's all I can handle of
Opie all right man I did my best